qui à l'école triche est très souvent
pendant les contrôles à paris ça et moi
moi grignotant mais parce qu'on voyait
rien vous trichez mathieu larocque
vous avez fait je faisais des ponts je
ne préparais pas mais je regardais à
droite à gauche ça mais est ce qu un
à-côté paix avait des gens qui faisaient
ça vous connaissiez la bave qui mettait
le classeur à sa mère et à ben ouais bah
moi je me suis fait chier à foumbot avec
apprennent aussi révisé moi je m'en
rappelle y avait un mec thomas brisson
il mettait toujours son classeur comme
ça oui avec michel tu as fait quoi comme
études
moi j'ai fait sciences éco et anglais
one neige quoi business et wais à froid
et climatisation
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est en mai c'est au total et nous fait
franchement avec ardisson et jean pierre
foucault tu aurais fait sortir sur leur
plateau frère sur l'anneau aqoci batch
et de ses pics à week-end iv devait dit
que vous connaissez la technique de la
colle la technique de la colonne a su un
machin est en fait on avait un site sur
internet quand aimé ça ne venait de
sortir et en fait on s'envoyait les
cours et on avait une copine qui
dirigeait le texte honteux ça où tout a
déboulé curiae comme ça on connaît tous
le texte autour de la colle et en fait
il y avait juste je me rappelle moi je
vous ai raconté quand j'ai pris un
jogging de groupe 1 et que j'écris tout
le court soldo guînes de mourabaha non
mais sur la tête de ma mère j'ai pris un
jury ce que je voulais qu'ils soient
très grand et le jogging était limogé
prix blogging de mon père j'ai écrit
tout sur le jogging et tout le contrôle
je tirais sur le logo mais à la fin j'ai
dit ni comme au club et c'est pardon
mais le temps que vous mettez à guînes
j'ai passé toute une nuit contre le
savez les yeux de castany je te jure est
une a écrit méthyle sa mère non mais
voilà il voyait rien un autre truc nous
a raconté aussi quand un jour pendant
l'interclassé ce que voit castaldi brian
sur à regarder ça va
[Applaudissements]
la voix il a pris mon chien pour une
mouche alors non meilleur et scène
pendant la terre classe tu te rappelles
issa ou pas et on a le droit d'aller en
classe sur pour pour réviser j'avais
fait un truc moi c'est que j'avais tout
écrit sur une table pendant avant le
contrôle où tout me contrôler d'histoire
sur la tête de la mairie qui met la
table au premier rang et la prof elle
arrive je suis tout seul aux concurrents
je suis tranquille j'ai rien fait à
personne elle fait annuler à passer au
dernier rang c'est pourquoi moi andy va
dit pas ce que tu vaux dernier jeudi
d'accord mais je prends la table avec
moi elle dit ouais parce qu'il y avait
des tables lisse et les tables un peu le
truc j'ai pris la table je suis parti au
bout et ses rires et ses deux ans après
la grille on m'a dit qu'est ce que c'est
sur jboss et pas ce doit être un mec qui
passe l'amour à travers cinq premiers
ont donc fait la balance a justement
c'est pour pâques grille vous alors vous
il paraît que dans les grottes de
lascaux
oui mais moi je trichais l'interrogation
mais son bulletin après à oui et quand
il ya vingt-trois je m'étais 8
c'était un car je m'étais sais pas où
est sympa ça c'est fait ça pendant 34
ans ils se sont jamais rendus compte de
rien on sefrou ça c'est de la folie ans
à verser mon choix sinon je signe à la
place de ma mère ce qui fait que la même
signature qu'elle ment ouais c ur du
rythme des années mais c'est vrai cet
imbécile mais c'est en train de négocier
pour toi m'emmerde patron ce moment et
c'est chaud de sa propre et j'étais
chaud sa prof ou était amoureux un peu
de sa propre salle du bas parce que lui
la voyais très peu telle qu'elle est et
sud est même allé non
non là la prof de maths
la prof de maths à 9 sorti avec elle
quoi vont ils à pécho sa programmation
mais son nom parce qu'il est encore
vivant mais moi ce point dans quelques
classes sont présents étaient j'étais en
gt en seconde pas encore selon l'utp un
mineur il ya 20 ans ce qui en fait le
second lui sert il avait 25 ans elle est
là j'ai ramené tout le monde à l'erreur
22 23 24 ans non et en fait il y avait
eu alors il y avait un bouquin qui
s'appelle bille en tête l'époque qui
m'avait fasciné pas faire pas de fret et
maintenant c'est l'histoire d'un jeune
homme qui avait eu une aventure avec une
femme plus âgée
ce que vous pouvez ouvrir plus beaux
dunks que vous pouvez l'ouvrir et donc
où les ou l'autre alors dont et donc
j'étais pas très bons en maths elle m'a
dit mais vient chez moi faire des cours
comme ça je vais craquer way s'est fait
expliquer les cours de maths et j'allais
chez elle et et après j'ai fait beaucoup
de mathématiques voilà nom est très
bonne rentrée en fait je souhaite me
tall encore vivante parce que je sais
qu'elle est encore vivante encore alors
soit pas craindre être contente vous
l'avez ma mère elle vous le dire que
c'est vrai générale a alors abattu le
dimeet au voisin refus du livre met émis
par quoi nous allons je me suis alors
oui moi quand j'étais plus jeune c'était
déjà très beau je faisais les longitudes
difficile
quoi et jae c était donc en première
année de fac pour des études d'économie
et la prof de fac était assez jeune dort
une petite 30 ou 32 ans j'en avais 19 32
j'ai bien vu qu'elle me regarder un
petit peu et qu'elle n'était pas fallait
pas bien compris ce qui se passait donc
et j'avais du mal avec les examens je
lui propose de prendre un verre elle a
accepté
nous avons couché est là qui fait la
part sombre
bref c'est moi juste vous rappeler
qu'avec quinze fois que nous la raconter
cette histoire oui a batu bouquet les
braises mais je veux à bon alors voilà
pas répondre à la fin ça on ne vend plus
du manque pas quoi voulez vous donne que
michel la connaissez pas qu'à la fin il
m'a donné l'examen a donné les questions
de l'examen
je les ai passées et puis en chine fois
que j'ai une bonne note michel je le
regrette pour les femmes savent et et
vous serais resté gelé dégager des
lendemains et je les sorties de ma vie
avec mon examen voilà une anecdote pour
les mâles étaient mieux que vous la
raconter plus avant alors jimmy et jim
et moi m c'est celui qui a fait le plus
d'études médecin c'est bac + 2 sec 9 10
a dépensé des gens mais oui backis à 9
ou 10 ça dépend des saris et elle a
maintenant quoi datant d il a fait beau
film a fait pâlir après le bac tu as
fait 10,6 en un mois après le bac j'ai
fait dix jours
c'est un truc nouveau le bois pour le
bakoye qui est un qui n'a pas son bac
easy way mais kelly merci c'est assumer
c'est tout c'est la seule c'est que
kenny qui n'a pas son bac comment
quitter l'asnl n'a pas d'origine et qu
il sait pas non mais moi je vais le
passer dans la mêlée
dia libre vous avez passé maquillage 58
ans est ravie d'annoncer un bac par
exemple 10 à 10 ans qu'est ce que ça
vaut aujourd'hui où il ya vingt ans
passés parce qu'un médecin de 1900 qui
voudraient travailler aujourd'hui patois
jimmy les genres il arriverait avec son
truc avec les sigles et inadapté une
fois il faut un bac actuelle passer
chaque année sur la tête de ma mère je
viens d'avoir une idée de ouf
l'année prochaine ou balasko candidat
dit on va les réviser toute l'année
c'est silva banon et l'année prochaine
on lui fera passer son bac et on va voir
les notes qui va avoir maintenant il
oubliera